Monday season 14 premiere of America's
Got Talent was chock-full of excitement
entertainment and emotion mainly thanks
to the final contestant of the night 22
year old Cody Lee who was joined onstage
by his mom
Cody is blind and autistic we found out
that he loved music really early on I
was in tears because that's when I
realized oh my gosh he's an entertainer
Cody took a seat at the piano and we
truly weren't ready for what happened
next new judges this season Julianne
Hough and Gabrielle Union teared up
watching Cody's stunning performance
I just feel so grateful that now we get
a chance to be here and be a part of I
don't know just making making dreams a
reality for these contestants I love
being a part of making dreams come true
it's nice to be a part of saying yes
to someone's dreams Gabrielle gave Kody
a yes but not just any old yes
and tonight I'm gonna give you
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll look over and I see like it there
welled up with tears so they they feel
it yet they tell it it's such a
wonderful kind of strong empathetic
place to be and panel to sit on because
of these two Cody wasn't the only
standout performer of the night everyone
flipped for fifteen-year-old Sophie
pakora who performed an original song
about the not so fun parts of growing up
torn down in the seventh grade all the
things people used to say I've heard the
words won't take them to my grave Sophie
scored four yeses which means she's
moving on to the next round
same with Brian aka the human fuse whose
name is pretty self-explanatory
[Applause]
new contestants and new judges it's
already shaping up to be quite a big
season of AGT ET sat down with the new
ladies of the panel where they share
their approach to giving feedback now I
mean I think we all kind of have our own
you know taste in an Italian and we all
are sort of unafraid to articulate that
we all kind of have our own lanes and
we're not afraid to sort of you know
switch gears and cross over into traffic
and some of us move slower and some of
us move faster and it's all ok and it's
all beautiful I think the empathy that
we bring I think is is authentic I think
we really want people to succeed and so
when we have to tell them no hopefully
they know it's coming from a place of
encouragement to keep going